how's it going bros Negus fear
welcome back janeshia wide night I might
not actually figured but this is
actually I'm Asian
we're in this friggin corner and it
weights a lot of ah ah my hairs ha ok
this is for you
I didn't really need batteries really
neat about it first priority batteries
right now
could they be bet now not there maybe
the office yeah
maybe and it's so dark I get really
can't see [ __ ] I don't even know where
where my buddies I haven't seen better
than tigey it's disappointing my my
berries all the rather like my [ __ ]
on I'm like where my better than where
my berries at tell me mister but no or
if you refuse to cooperate don't you
about this wall smash but now that's
what you get that's what you're freaking
it mr. share get out of me I'm pissed
alright fine fine I need a tool to open
it maybe a crowbar could do it how
freakin convenient that's that's alright
oh no my crowbar what is this what is
this mr. share did you I watched my
pants where you think I can hold a
crowbar now now it's impossible I forgot
go out of a flannel steam every frickin
time surprise no one wrote to me alright
ok yes got my screwdriver
let's go mister share but I want to
start out alright find which flavor mmm
let me think
damn I think today please visit mashing
up to watch don't you pay alright I want
lemonade sorry I don't have any change
are you [ __ ] I hate you okay Oh No
how are you okay that's a sheriff
we need batteries that was first
priority right I need my berries we
gotta leave in there I can't see [ __ ]
it's so dark it's annoying [ __ ] [ __ ]
why did I click her and why and hot it's
too hard here to pack okay meeting room
now now we in a room reaction now not
bragging groups it's definitely over
here I can change I can change any of my
touch mattress I wonder if it's still
haunted
salted penis is I get out
like we need some freaking progress in
here don't we it's up here though I am
can't go there
down here was like super dark right yep
I don't want to go there
I hate darkness actually on the dark
night of course I like oh what's going
on it oh yeah is black man
I don't even know anymore there's gotta
be batteries here somewhere is a
freaking storage room I don't understand
where my batteries that way my bed with
my batteries where my batteries there I
was like bomba that's good
that's something in this give me
batteries give me batteries give me
batteries where my batteries
do you have my batteries tell me the
truth I know your box but seriously
though where my batteries there bear I
need berries wait was there maybe that
was batteries
batteries no they drink again maybe I
can use this all this [ __ ] marked it's
dark as hell can't see [ __ ] instead of
missing hello Danny what are you now I'm
sleeping Jesus Christ be careful all
right fine
I need berries but it's this it's
another mr. share this is impossible I
can't see [ __ ] I need to increase the
gamma just in this room I'm cheating
okay fine fine decide I really can't see
[ __ ] oh oh yeah there's a light switch
as I do anything so creepy alright now I
can turn it down I think sorry about
that
alright it's just I increase the I
increase it while a afternoon when I
save the video I increase the brightness
for YouTube so don't think sit down be
like I itch Friday I catch an Frank why
are you talking about it shows an idiot
its needy no no it's not sure
stop cheer with shame nah of course not
ok what you do where my batteries at
seriously my friggin batteries and I'm
getting pissed
are we yes yes yes ok I think we can
progress now actually holy [ __ ]
how's the noise alright
let's go am I the only one who think the
hand looks [ __ ] really that I love
spitting it was so dark but I'm glad you
finally got damn I thought that one turn
up the lie don't even know anymore okay
I think the court is five and then I
forgot wait I wrote it down somewhere
because you know I I had a five six to
three there we go let's go Stefano all
right Billy
hey everybody let's see what's in there
what's going on it's loading
my murse again Hyundai that no I hope
you will be banner today but you are not
house it turns out hmm what's happened
to me why is there no one but me in this
place I don't understand it make
something there then you remember me in
your name yeah good you finally started
to show Brooke hey what progress what
are you talking about I like a few fresh
grown I'd it's fragile David I'm afraid
yours is heavily broken but don't worry
I'm here to heal your mom hey he's gonna
heal him DDS stop saying that
cheers guys he's perfect aggressive
today are with a my doing here it's good
to see you're ambitious let's start a
session today then all right fine what
happened to me I just want to talk to
mr. sharp eye definer yes forgot I've
been to you David but let's take us know
you should know you're a good person
Nathan but there are bad things you made
no it's impossible
I've been done anything wrong Kelly mr.
Shannon you I would I'm not good person
all right mister sure I don't ya see I'm
a good Berlin how can you be so sure
than David exactly how can you how can
she be sure don't trust him mr. Pirie
Josh Turner seen that body statement yes
relation to me really don't trust it I
don't know we're seeing dead body actors
want to kill you pay I'm your friend
me David don't listen to the doctor come
with me
when me my share you can trust me I
always been weird assigned I always been
by your side Petey I mean by your but
more technically they which is why you
should love me even more I mean not a
lot of people were like what like you
said on your face yeah it's not very
good for me but I do it because I love
you you can trust me on my share all
right what's going on here
I need my morph in I need it bad okay
I'm luckily a flashlight but there's no
light switch here I need to be quick get
run out of life batteries any more
batteries I picked up didn't even give
me a quarter I need my Swift
I need a fight what the heck is going on
here right now this hex the computer
didn't work let's lift some [ __ ] I find
a battery good maybe we have more time
after all downstairs keys perfect
okay let's go eisah fauna huh so creepy
Jesus Christ downstairs observation room
where's downstairs
this may be ah okay let's see what's in
here
downstairs where's down sex
I mean it's officer Bob sir what do you
think shot I don't know what seriously
though you need to vote stop spinning me
around all right
downstairs is obviously over here you
stupid ass huh
Howard here's answer I told ya I break
it down a minute Jesus Christ you gave
me headaches all right put me down and
open the door
you're so controlling Stefano I'm just
your friend don't be so angry ology all
right all right all right I'm gonna put
you here Stefano is it safe
yes it's safe okay patients wards locked
us so Phi I'd so I could address
duration was the hike Andrey let's left
has finished nearly possible the patient
was she said patiently craft you to
continue I so I took the files an
examination made list you need somehow
have them to continue the work John
Barker Richard Christian for Thomas
redwood David it's impossible to read
do it do it to bad handwriting alright
why do you think about that huh
now their key huh not a key that's good
that's good for me me my keys and some
are two batteries I'm a happy people
today
attacks computers ah we can hello
alright heck am i over here alright I
think we got what we came for
oh [ __ ] Stefano's jealous Jeremy this is
I don't want to be here this is creepy
yeah I want to go here and scream
yourself let's get out of here
good ideas fun good freakin idea I don't
even know anymore
okay it's not wait for fire fire good
job
you always waste a frigging flashlight
I'm seriously pissed off at you pretty
okay where was the key going to patient
wing I think uh what y'all are you doing
sorry Jesus Christ don't be angry
thinking again
page observation room I'm out of battery
come on patients observation patient
observation
why am i upside down Jesus Christ
feeling here I don't even know anymore
no these are freakin background noise
Jesus penas all my large everywhere
what is this of God no I want to read
that
this'll slow era highway my projection
bunk I thought I found it
ah we're not finding it are we safe on
up I don't even know like I'm seriously
pissed off at this one right now me too
me too
all right doctor swing no I don't even
know why it's gotta be Jesus Christ it's
freaking background noise is so annoying
whatever let's try this
no of course not
observation room ya know hey I've
already been in here
patience patience maybe it was
downstairs
it would make sense I don't even know
anymore like chiffon oh you're not
telling me off you're just hanging there
what's this for super creepy good
oh really yeah [ __ ] oh oh my [ __ ]
foot ah
oh that's seriously [ __ ] heart ah ah
my foot first my leg and now my iPhone's
say ah I heard more the bud ah come on
it's not fair oh man it's probably here
yeah okay fine
oh oh my foot ah ah ah come on
alright uh okay this way pity I'm
seriously getting tired is freaking it's
not gonna open well let's see about that
okay
huh no nothing there what the [ __ ] is up
with this room then this showers people
getting raped good ol slab and here have
same old [ __ ] as usual
alright yeah that's perfect
open you [ __ ] dumb Brad Brad come
here spider
I don't even care anymore it's annoying
the flash lighting Laden's son is
pissing me off okay yes yes yes yes the
drawers and [ __ ] [ __ ] love drawers
man I was born in a drawer you know good
times good times like good times in the
drawer
I took my first poo in the drawer and I
had my first bath and I'm Laurin why am
i checking all of these rooms why am i
doing this why ha ha it's all that holy
[ __ ] hold it matters ah
let's get out of here ok over here I see
oh oh please tell me I get the ax
Oh [ __ ] please tell me I get axed if I
know I'm gonna use it what are you doing
no don't done holy [ __ ] what did you do
all right it's fine for now
I try to give you for this one thank you
for smaller and see what this door has
to do let's freakin do this
now
No huh fine I don't need me oh yeah I
know I know
here here here here of course it's the
right shut up ha ha ha here's the phone
up alright
I feel better now whoa this [ __ ] hole
didn't bed alright we're good
ok alright just going here
ah I'll bet thank you spot up all right
let's see what I spawn here I gotta
leave your spot oh it's okay PD but
remember don't track the dot don't trust
the doctors you can trust me mr. Sher
and that's pretty much it
I'll see you on the other side all right
I'll see you Stefano I know I can make
it by
what's she telling married what's she
telling me to touch her huh okay I was
just kidding
I'm tired I'm sorry I'm